in the beginning of the pandemic was the
first time ever i opened my mouth on
social media and i remember
it was when we started to reopen and we
realized okay we can start to serve
through third-party delivery
and we became a pillar in the community
and our sales started to pick up about
three weeks after the initial lockdown
so we reached out to a significant
amount of the people who we had
originally laid off
now remember i mentioned those were
people who were living at home college
students working with mom
you know kind of living with mom and dad
and
all of them i'm not being sarcastic when
i tell you this rejected the offer to
come back because they said i'm making
twelve hundred dollars or eleven hundred
dollars a week now on unemployment why
would i come back and work
what was going through your mind those
first couple weeks you know you had the
first two weeks it seems like a lifetime
ago but two weeks to flatten the curve
and
if i remember correctly everyone
basically obeyed no questions asked like
oh two weeks we'll do what we got to do
did you kind of feel that as as an owner
of a restaurant and then when did you
realize oh
maybe something ain't right here yeah
bingo exactly for the first two weeks
that's what everybody was thinking and i
and i
joke about this and i say that's when
the cliche really was true we all were
in it together and then we kind of put
our business capes on at that point
because we
had let a lot of our employees go
unfortunately because we didn't know
what was going to happen so
we were almost encouraged by the
business community that yeah you know
you lay everybody off the government's
going to be really easy about making
sure that they get the unemployment
benefits and then you can just or
furlough them and then you can take them
back aboard so
we tried to only lay off those that were
either
you know working from college living
with mom and dad
who kind of wanted the unemployment
benefits and then we kept on a lot of
our team members who were you know
sole providers for their family and we
pivoted immediately to be able to feed
all the first responders right police
emt
fire uh and then those on the me in the
medical field
and you know what was pretty funny about
that i joke
i tell this little story we were giving
free food to anybody who was a first
responder in these kind of broad
categories
and you know people picked up on that
right away so even within the first two
weeks of the lockdown
we had people showing up for takeout
they would go buy scrubs
for like a dollar to get their free
livestream so the grift was in
from the very right so when when did you
realize though that like oh
this is this is way beyond two weeks and
we we got a much bigger problem here
well when everyone started to and over
intellectualized the numbers right
it was all about this you know it it
kept getting
higher and higher and higher in regards
to altitude right so by altitude i mean
we're we're grounded in the beginning
it's very easy to understand
two weeks we flatten the curve we give
the hospitals opportunity to
increase you know all the necessary ppp
and the equipment they need in order to
deal with this pandemic
but then it goes into the next level
right in the stratosphere where it's
okay well now we have these metrics
about icu capacity
and then the numbers and we started to
play this overly intellectualized game
of math
where businesses couldn't even keep up
anymore uh so then
it was almost as if we were confounded
by the numbers
and just forced back into these
lockdowns over and over and over
and you talk about just like the
personal side of when you had to make
calls or meet people or whatever it was
when you had to lay them off or furlough
them because i've met a lot of
restauranteurs over the last year more
than i've ever met
in my entire life and most of the ones
at least that i've met here in la
they're not particularly political
people they they suddenly they've been
mugged by politics so now they're
political but most of them really were
just upset about having to lay off
people you know people that had to lay
off chefs that have been working with
them
for 30 years i met one guy who owned
something like 40 restaurants had to lay
off almost a thousand people
like and this is this is serious stuff
yeah we're and we were at a point a
trajectory if you will in
in our business we had just kind of
finished recapitalizing the company so
we actually had just brought on some new
positions
from a corporate perspective and we were
trying to grow the franchise angle
and then it was an immediate sorry like
we just brought you on but we got to let
you go
and uh we let a lot of people go and my
wife and i it was just the two of us we
kept on a couple key players on the
corporate side
you know i stopped taking a salary it
was really about survival at that point
but the hardest thing was trying to
explain the people who didn't
necessarily understand what was going on
a significant portion workforce they
don't speak english that well many of
them look frankly
are uh you know don't necessarily
understand the government framework in
the united states so it was okay you're
letting me go but am i going to get paid
i don't want to file for unemployment
because i'm kind of afraid of government
systems so
a lot of hand-holding my wife was
getting phone calls almost at every hour
of the day
trying to explain to people don't worry
we're going to be able to bring you back
on board we're going to loan you some
money we're going to help you out in
this regard we're here for you
and that was the hardest part how
stressful was it for you
financially i mean you're laying off
people to save some money but
you had no idea when things were going
to open and even now things are still
weird
yeah we didn't have the cash flow to be
able to sit back comfortably and say
we're going to see this thing through
we didn't you know we had debt being
called in regards to all the different
businesses as i had mentioned with my
my other concept butter leaf uh it was
it was immediate right like i still had
what was really fascinating about this
was i was still getting phone calls
from sales and use tax right the board
of equalization on sales tax saying okay
the year's up now you owe x amount of
dollars and i'm we're not even open
right we're in the middle of a pandemic
they don't care i'm getting letters in
the mail that not only tack on the
amount that we owe
and i'm talking within the first month
of the pandemic but adding interest
and penalties and then more interest on
the penalties that never stops man
it's just crazy so were you did you
consider yourself kind of political
before this
we've talked off the record once or
twice i have a sense of what your
politics are now i can tell
obviously on twitter too but were you
political before any of this stuff
i've always been fascinated by politics
i was in model un youth and government
growing up in high school
i volunteered for multiple senators my
uh you know she was uh
she's an urban planner so you kind of
have to be across the board so it was
always imbued
in my environment but i was never really
really vocal about it and i always knew
not to be vocal about it
what was really interesting in the in
the in the restaurant space is that
i joke about how really chefs are all
libertarians you know you have anthony
bourdain who frankly i believe has
had some amazing uh we'll call them
quotes when it comes to the ways in
which government affects or doesn't
affect the restaurant world and
everything beyond
but everybody knows especially in
california just kind of keep your mouth
shut
and even in orange county right but
in the beginning of the pandemic was the
first time ever i opened my mouth on
social media and i remember
it was when we started to reopen and we
realized okay we can start to serve
through third-party delivery
and we became a pillar in the community
and our sales started to pick up about
three weeks after the initial lockdown
so we reached out to a significant
amount of the people who we had
originally laid off
now remember i mentioned those were
people who were living at home college
students working with mom you know
kind of living with mom and dad and all
of them
i'm not being sarcastic when i tell you
this rejected the offer to come back
because they said i'm making
twelve hundred dollars or eleven hundred
dollars a week now on unemployment why
would i come back and work
and i get it right yeah we said okay i
understand i would love to be able to
make the same amount of money read some
books take care of the kids
um so i don't hold them you know
accountable for that decision but i
posted that anecdote just on twitter
and man it went it blew up it went
completely viral
and i started getting attacked you know
along the lines of oh well if only you
paid your employees
more then they wouldn't be able to do
that if you only provided them health
care et cetera et cetera and it
immediately became a divisive debate
when all i was merely doing was just
saying hey this is what's happening out
there in the business world
right because even if you paid them
double that some of them might be like
ah it's still not worth it because i can
get half for free
and it's like there's no economics
behind it in essence
exactly well even a lot of the people
who are having come back because we do
pay a significant amount of money for
people to work in the restaurant and
then add tips into that they were making
about 35
an hour front of the house so let's say
they were bringing in fifteen hundred
dollars a week but now they bring in a
thousand
by virtue of the unemployment they're
still
netting a thousand dollars to not work
right so it's not a matter of it's not
an apples-to-apples comparison
people didn't care about that it was
here's my position and here's what
what's going to happen so it just became
at that point i realized okay well you
know what i'm not going to
sit back anymore i'm going to dig in on
this and i'm not i'm not going to be a
dick about it but i'm going to use real
life stories
to kind of back up some of these
platitudes was that kind of the first
moment that you decided to really get
more vocal about all this
yup yup that was exactly it that was the
moment right there and it's funny
because if you go through and you do a
full
you know uh uh search which i'm sure
many people have done of my social
you will see that that was the moment in
time everything before that was
mayonnaise and fart jokes
that was when you put the red pill in
the
lobster roll apparently um what was it
like those okay so then you get
confronted with that issue did you have
trouble getting guys back then because
of that
i mean did you have to hire new people
yeah yeah we did we had to hire new
people we had to completely uh
alter our operations so for me it's i'm
not always i'm not going to sit back and
cry and complain it's okay well what can
i do to get ahead of this so once i
realized that one of the barriers was
going to be
having accessibility to a strong labor
force okay well then we're going to
automate
our systems right so immediately it was
co-packing a lot of our sauces which we
previously made in-house
spices etc so trying to decrease the
units of labor that we need in order to
provide a high quality product without
of course compromising
what our original mission was as a
restaurant do you sense that some
restaurants
and i don't blame them actually because
it all just sucks but do you sense that
that many are starting to cut corners
and things and the reason i ask that
is you know you know because of my
twitter i mean we cook a lot around here
so i've only gone out to restaurants a
couple of times but i've noticed that a
bunch of the restaurants
stuff is just not as good and i kind of
don't blame them for a having to cut
corners
but also like the zest for life that a
chef would have when they get to see
customers and get feedback and get
compliments
as opposed to just sort of being a robot
now on these takeout orders
bingo and you know i always joke i say
food
is representative of life um and by that
i mean
if you know if you're in a you know
everyone's partying and everything's
great et cetera et cetera it's like you
remember the flavors of the food you ate
in the midst of that right
the spice the pepper the acids the pop
this and that the hard char right just
this
overly amplified food and right now what
are we living through we're living
through a time where
absolutely everybody feels hopelessness
despair anxiety depression etc and i
think food is reflecting that so yes i
agree 100
with your point but i'm not just seeing
it in the restaurant space i'm also
seeing
in the hospitality space i traveled a
lot throughout the pandemic
and what i noticed was that people were
using the pandemic as a means by which
they could
increase profits cut corners but of
course blame the pandemic right so
no housekeeping no room service et
cetera et cetera you know old bars of
soap with hair in it
you name it if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell